okay well for people who are joining
this livestream this is one of our
series of the language completeness and
consistency meetings about orphan
language features alright let's start
off first thing here okay this has to do
with the epilogue of graphics and
whether there should be a 3d analog of
epilogue so do we have them Brett here
yes okay so I mean epilogue is you know
these are ancient creatures well it's
not just ancient creatures I mean they I
mean there's a reason for those two
examples there which is to make sure we
all understand what they are they're
actually for okay so what coordinate
system does it use in 3d scale zero one
system in 2d I see on the image is
useful no question I mean there's
nothing wrong with what it's doing right
now right so the purpose of epilogue is
to draw something of on top of your
image and Prolog is something below your
image and this is the same in 2d and 3d
now in 2d right you have layers and 3d
you have a three dimensional coordinate
system but prologue and epilogue are
always all the way above are all played
below I see so your point is in 3d but
above and below or just you know you
just throw in various 3d primitives and
they'll be where it is ranked right I
suppose using a sphere as opposed to a
cylinder or something wasn't necessarily
the best choice there but but point the
bubbler is making here is that for lists
point plot 3d that's the issue okay so
the issue is at the scene right
now I mean arguably I don't quite
understand why we're not just using okay
so let's imagine we do this okay now we
say show that like sphere or we can't do
that can we we have to say graphics 3d
mm-hm
let's say sphere you know 50 50 50 comma
30 now is that gonna work yes so what
the heck is wrong with that there's
nothing wrong with it per se I mean I
think we're where people get confused
are people who you know think of Epilog
as a way to write people come from plot
where you can just add something using
epilogue and in 3d you have to use show
yeah right which is very I personally
have been slightly annoyed by this right
because you need to go so the choice
would be to have an epilogue 3d right
but that would I think that would only
make sense as an option to visit
functions not as 3d I agree I mean
graphics 3d it's kind of no up it's just
like it could be append to the list by
itself doesn't evaluate no I understand
that but I mean it will be equivalent to
put an epilogue 3d in there would be I
mean unfortunately these names are
awfully generic but but well the
epilogue 3d is not as generic a name but
so the idea then would be in this case
here and I don't think this is totally
stupid at all
with me to have an epilogue 3d arrow
like let's say sphere scaled
something like this right what I mean I
don't think that's objectionable I I
don't know I mean it's kind of
asymmetric that we don't have a prologue
3d because obviously we don't need it
well I mean to some extent it's not
really
epilogue either right you know it's some
extra content well you could you could
append that content to the list of
primitives that you have and in that
sense it's an epilogue and you could
prepend
just as easily and I'd get the same
result yes I'm aware right but my point
is right I think the way right I mean we
would need John filters somebody from
the fronton team if you actually wanted
to change graphics 3d I mean as an
option to visualizations functions right
we just effectively do the show for the
user and stick it in the graphics 3d
option to graphics 3d directly then we
have to think well I don't think
anybody's going to look for it there I
mean I think that as a practical matter
adding it to the visualization functions
is a reasonable thing to do I'd rather
edit to graphics 3d well you could you
can negotiate with John what you want to
do with that you too might be able to do
this okay in any case all right fine so
can we agree on this I think is that the
name that we I think it's the name we
should use because I think anything else
that you know says sort of extra
graphics or something like this it's
just gonna be totally confusing and I
think what people are looking for is an
analog of epilogue
right there's I certainly use epilogue
much more than you use prologue in in
your plot commands because we want to
draw things on top of the plot you just
created right on that sense having an
epilogue I mean I can imagine that image
3d could eventually support an epilogue
3d as well yeah probably
and I assume that the Geographics
functions support epilogue right now yes
because they just inherit from graphics
okay all right fine I think this is
reasonable let's do it I have a question
about coordinate systems so because they
knew I mean the mission functions use
scaling functions which coordinate
system is this size that you put at the
end the 20 this is just going to be
thrown into the list of graphics
primitives so whatever coordinate system
that list of graphics primitives thinks
it's in that's where we'll be in right
which is another thing that surprises
people because in the 2d case right it
is using the same coordinate system as
as the plot whereas in 3d it's the
scaled 0 1 coordinate system right which
is a reason to have an epilogue 3d which
people will find if they're looking for
this kind of behavior but that's
referring to the center of the sphere
not the radius of the sphere I was
asking about the radius of the sphere
that 20 is what's wrong with that I mean
it just gets thrown into the list of
garbage no I'm sorry I mean so if you
look it likes a log plot right the
coordinate system is the log scaled one
okay you know sort of epilogue and
prologue or is it sort of very low level
we sorts of things so after taking that
already knows mm-hmm okay
yeah so actually what do epilogue and
prologue do with love and you need to
take the lock yourself or you need to
take the logs yourself really that is
really how it works right now think
about that because it seems correct
crazy to me so the coordinate system is
well I guess it's not crazy
given the craziness of the epilogue in a
3d graphic which is just saying to heck
with the coordinate system with the user
coordinate system in the in the graphic
it's just going to use the zero one
coordinate system right rent I mean in
graphics the coordinate systems are
anything completely different for
epilogue and prologue because if you
want the scale then you have to
explicitly use scaled and what are you
saying here so so let's see you know
it's crazy that we don't reproduce all
of the code all of the things we really
should do that you have all of options
graphics yes yes yes there's some crazy
stuff in options graphics yes and it
makes for some pretty long table itself
I suppose there are pluses in my
this is the pose
yeah I was gonna say there's probably a
third of options of graphics that I
don't even ever use well that's a
separate discussion maybe I could maybe
you could look at that Brett and maybe
we could maybe we could at least bring
in the ones because I mean clearly here
whatever if there is a weird behavior of
epilogue it is certainly not documented
here right date list plot the dates are
what unix time and that's that's not
obvious either like it like any
different coordinate system like dates
is gonna be confusing as well yes yeah
but I mean with respect to epilogue
you're saying yeah like if you wanted to
use epilogue with like a dated plot for
example I think what do you have to do I
think you have to use it so didn't even
document epilogue and the options here
there might be something under possible
issues I don't remember if that got
added or not
probably not but
I mean on the other hand you have
functions like pie chart and bar chart
where you know the coordinate system in
one or both directions is sort of
philosophically non-existent or at least
none yeah but then there's a right but
by the way switch might if you could
report the stupid bug that those parens
are too big they're um okay so what is
your basic point here so your point is
that epilog for something like a bar
chart epilogue is just punting to going
to treating that as a zero on coordinate
system is that correct
no no no the visualization functions
just pass that to graphics and so
whatever is the actual coordinate system
of the graphics produced none of the
tick marks but if the graphics this is
what you need to be in what so wait a
second wait a second wait that wasn't so
if I say pie chart was gonna do this let
me do this
epilogue is this going to be crazy so if
I say epilogue disk
you know 1.5 1.5 it's gonna put it where
you would expect where that's the zero
zero of the coordinate system and that
pie chart has radius one okay where does
it ever say that in the pie chart
documentation it doesn't does it say it
in the epilogue documentation I'm sure
it doesn't
brilliant okay okay well I mean so the
thing is like like pie chart I think has
you know hasn't ever changed but you
know the x coordinate system in bar
charts has adjusted you know a little
bit over the years
George on the livestream is pointing out
the role of yeah we know that the role
of yes the role of epilogue is to put
things in the 2d coordinate system and I
think what we're concluding here is that
I mean okay what about a 3d graphic like
a bar chart 3d yeah I mean look
basically what okay first point is
clearly it needs to be documented what
coordinate system epilogue is actually
using in these different things I mean
presumably if I do a show things if I do
a show with the pie chart here I mean
right so I mean I would claim it is
documented in the sense that right it's
you know the rough page for pie chart
says it has the same options and
graphics with the following changes
since epilogue is not listed there that
means it treats it exactly the same as
if you did show where does it say what
the coordinate system of the pie chart
is well that it doesn't say but job
that's not know I agree I agree but pie
chart could say well it's coordinate
system is which is relevant also for
this show I just did correct right
although I mean the coordinate system
for pie chart is arbitrary yeah but it's
something definitely I mean I'd my
concern is documenting something that
down the line we suddenly have some you
know real reason for wanting to joke I
think we should think through what they
will are why don't we inventory what
they are and see whether we feel
embarrassed by any of them I don't feel
embarrassed by a pie chart going from 0
0 to Center to being a radius 1 pie
chart that doesn't seem embarrassing to
me this let's see whether they're all as
unembarrassed in as that
and if so for example Steven yeah I'll
give you two examples so going back to
is a dateless plot where right now the
x-coordinate is absolute time yeah
that's ridiculous
I don't really should be but but it
shouldn't be that it should be something
that's on a much more reasonable scale
of 0 to 1 or unix time or something that
you know isn't in billions or whatever
well okay so that's a good question what
is the absolute graphics coordinate
system of dateless plot as opposed to
what so here's another question dateless
plot is an example of something where we
need epilogue 3d like behavior so for
example on a dateless plot if you wanted
to put an arrow to a particular date how
would you do it that's where you want
essentially a contextual epilogue that
just throws you know graphics primitives
into the you know how do I do if I just
have graphics where I've got you know
now to let's say I have something like
this now to let's say how about day
range date okay now now plus oops
now plus two weeks okay okay so now what
I want to do is I want to take those
let's say I just do a to do this
transpose ray
okay so now I can do a dateless plot on
that and now what I want to know is how
do I insert an extra data point here in
that dateless plot get what I'm saying
so right now if you do epilogue then you
have to yeah it's absolutely I mean what
epilogue should do in this case is I
should be able to say point and then I
should be able to say now the six or
something and that's just gonna go
bonkers isn't it
not gonna go bonkers why didn't that go
bonkers why didn't that go bonkers
actually I think dateless plots
I think Darren put in code that does the
translation okay I don't know how
comprehensive it is okay so let me
understand if I do a shot polygon around
a pointer hello well let's do yeah let's
do this instead of that
let's do regular polygons but it should
have been placed on the vertical of this
zero the first point right yes it's in
the wrong place no it isn't Jose because
we're mostly through today oh yeah right
you know it's today versus now oh it's
today versus no yes yes yes okay
radius centers yeah and then there's a
radius and then there's a number of
sides good luck with that radius I know
that's my point
six and then we'll do number of sides
okay okay so this radius is a big
crapshoot what I mean this is just for
fun can you try off set of five I don't
know whether regular polygons well
recently using seconds okay so this is
completely crazy yeah okay but so what
we're doing in 3d graphics is we're just
saying Epilog has a zero one coordinate
system no it's using the do range of
percent 138 or sorry options of the
percent 138 plot range 138 the data 140
but some 140 what do you want to do plot
range yep I think you want absolute
options no polygons is going to look not
very regular no I understand
and in the case of of Geographics what
would the analogous thing look like this
so if I do geography
well they did the Geographics case is
simpler for two reasons first the two
dimensions are always the same things
distances of on the earth slightly
deformed by by projections but they are
not completely two different things like
here and the second thing is that the
projections have a reference model
allowing to set a scale so depending on
the projection that's going to so what
is that that lat/longs
in this case this is long lat okay but
why if that doesn't correspond is that I
see this but there could be a this thing
is it's a slice to be rectangular even
though the projection with that long may
not be a rectangular region so if you
have a Geographics or these and just for
the Geo range you get through that long
if you ask for a plotter range you will
get the projected coordinates which
depend on the projection in this case
it's Mercator projection so you are
getting longitudes options percent 148
change right so there you are getting
latitudes yes and then longitudes
in the first case with plot range
because this is a Mercator projection
you are getting longitudes which are
identical and then the market or
latitudes which are always a bit larger
than the original ones so meerkat or the
vertical axis of do a geographic in my
opinion it's better to not think of that
there are fifty 6.99 in 149 as latitude
you know it's a projected coordinate
that is parallel to latitudes
I think you do something much more
unreasonable I want to do this um
and I never tried something like this he
do graphics and show yes we have to
it will reproduce your graphics we do
another Geographics what is this what is
this what an earth is this some weird
thing off the coast of is this off the
coast of Africa because it's yes that's
just crazy why why isn't using the the
range the range or do range of the first
one given that's what I was just
wondering yes it had it in the opposite
order I would have expected something
sort of like this well show with your
graphics because in general it's
designed to take two Geographics of two
different regions it will basically
ignore the Ruggiero ranges and it will
take the inputs and compute a new
Geographics but why isn't it including
Luxembourg I don't know I don't know so
what is this gonna do is that gonna show
Luxembourg and New York and Paris Lyon
expecting it will show a big chunk of
the world yeah that's independent yeah
no sometimes it happens that it this is
the retry we were discussing it tried to
get to unload a tile it couldn't but it
will try it and then then it has
succeeded apparently because I don't see
any tile missing here
right okay so this worked okay so we've
got some funkiness look the basic bottom
line is what is the the okay so first
question is what is the raw graphics
coordinate system of some of these more
derived plots okay of which stateless
plot is clearly kind of crazy you know
this one is at least sober I would say
what its actual you know we should
probably document what the actual
graphics coordinate system except Bret
is saying let's not document it because
we don't actually you know we're not
really committing to it I'm talking
about for some of the things I mean I
think that Gio let's plot the coordinate
system is welding the punky case is the
date list plot case and and if you do
plant well this right but then once you
support scaling and and scaling
functions then the coordinate systems
that all very counterintuitive well I
think what Brett was saying is that it
works like in Geographics which is the
important coordinate system systems at
the end is the one of the projected
space after you have taken the logarithm
or India after you have predicted okay
so listen I think bottom line here is we
need to do some investigation and Bret
should get somebody in his team to look
at this of what the actual coordinate
systems are for these various kinds of
graphics which for example with in the
case of dateless plot it looks just
fairly nutty well
well I mean with late list plot we need
to have some one-dimensional description
of the axis and absolute time has always
been and still is what we use internally
in many places including time cities for
example yeah so and it's not crazy I
mean given that we're gonna do this it's
I mean look the fact that it's what it's
January 0 1900 or something it's
relative to yes and it has been like
that all the time well okay so can I say
two things and hopefully they're so on
one hand you know if we come back to
this option that we came up with of
epilogue 3d yep I mean I'm wondering
whether it isn't more interesting to try
to come up with the more general the I
agree and then we documents that this
option adds elements to the scene and
pre pre transformation elements so that
means that this is a scaling function
thing then it's going to add elements
that are we take care of the transforms
yeah which means that in the case of
dateless plot we are assuming that the x
coordinates or time values etc mm-hm
but but then absolute time
a certain value as well but it's not
necessarily the only time value that
you're interested in I fully agree that
you should support date date object like
with the support $0.80 your position
state objects that doesn't raise that
doesn't solve the problem of what
happens when you combine with show you
know this thing with the with it's wacky
coordinate system I mean you know the
other thing that we're not doing here is
show you know we could imagine a form of
show which is basically the inset story
which just combines things assuming zero
on coordinate systems great right words
what we need is it's more like an
overlay than a show and we have an
overlay in fact but it does something
somewhat different I mean that's the
question is is if we were to have a
version of a conforming show where the
thing just assumed scaled coordinate or
scaled show or something
isn't that what incentives for well
that's what I just said yeah I think it
is right I mean instead it takes the
same ordering I wonder if we document
that very clearly with and I wonder if
this is impossible issues for things
like dateless plot and so on
all right look I agree that I think we
should come up with a more general but
you know as soon as we have an extra
elements thing the question is are they
epilogue elements or prologue elements
therefore because that's more useful
because on top mm-hm
well so what will we call it extra I
mean there's always
like epilogue elements but I don't like
that very much addendum I think addendum
sounds way too textual probably worked
up well plot annotations would be one
thing but I think that might be
confusing I mean it's not plantations
suggests the use for these which is not
necessarily actually plot additions or
plot extras plot label plot additions
it's not terrible plot additions I like
better than extras yeah and we've got
plot range we've got plot
I think plot additions is a reasonable
idea visualization yes that's true too
right so the other thing that I was
gonna mention yeah if you recall I say
two things the other is that I mean
conceivably at some point way down the
line I could imagine plot returning
things that are in where the coordinate
system under the hood used by plot is
zero one or some other completely
arbitrary scale and the reason for this
is that right now you know sort of plot
does the natural thing that it's done
for 30 years or whatever but this means
that if you have things that are beyond
10 to the 300 or whatever you know that
start going numbers that are beyond the
scale of Machine numbers that you run
into issues with you know the drawing
leaders at the OS level and things
become unrepresentable
that is a weird problem it is a weird
problem and but people run into it every
so often because you have you know
mathematical functions that get up that
big and then the plot behaves weirdly
Road where no we're not gonna fit we're
not gonna change the coordinate system
for plots for everything and makes show
not work for the sake of people who want
to plot things that are bigger than
machine numbers right so what would
frame true to what will be the tick's
would you show in the take zero to one
or ten to a million or whatever okay but
but it's not a million it's ten to the
300 you said ten to the 308 I would
guess central is a million is larger
than 10 to the 308 million okay I mean
look I think that case is totally crazy
and I think that case should be handled
in some different and much a Kia way
because what that's doing is that the
difficulty there is the drawing layer
can't handle those absolute coordinates
and I think the right answer to that is
probably some I mean you know the first
answer is wait until the drawing layer
can do it and let the user rescale it
until that time it sounds like a deeply
corner case I should take another look
at one of those examples because it's
possible that scaling functions should
already be able to work for it that
would be automatically and not
necessarily automatically but like right
now if you specify a scaling functions
it's just a rescale just a straight
linear no no I understand that but I'm
suggesting that in order to protect
against badness down the you know in the
rendering pipeline that you basically
just pull back on you know if you
discover that you're going to go you're
gonna blow out the rendering pipeline
then you automatically do the rescaling
as a which you could do with scaling
function
arrow automatic which we don't really
want to set but it could be that's sort
of some kind of panic scaling function
which maybe could be controlled by some
method option I think it's it's better
to you know that it a panic and do the
right thing so to speak in terms of what
appears clearly it will do the wrong
thing if you were to say show a 10 to
the 400 and a 10 to the 500 graphic
together and you did the right get the
wrong answer but you know what what's
gonna happen here
this will be a bug and you know that
that's better than that the thing just
blows out the rendering pipeline and
just produces something stupid you know
on your actual in the actual rendering
layer in the OS um that's what I would
do for that okay plot addition seems
like a good idea let's look through it
see whether we can make that work okay
okay I want to get on to my next topic
which is a lovely function that I know
everybody is going to attack but anyway
um we have a person already okay so
there's a function it's not going to be
called are kind of cute okay let me
explain what this is for
okay so the issue is if you're trying to
write a transposition sort function or
in general this is a
what is this this is a bunch of
exchanges to make so what this is doing
is it's taking the elements in a list
the specified the elements in a list at
specified positions and it is applying
this function to that list of elements
and then sticking the results from that
function which must have the same
cardinality so to speak as the original
element list and putting it back in the
positions of the original element list
did that make any sense to anybody so
[Music]
are we saying cardinality or not no I'm
saying I'm saying yes it's got to be the
same shape so this is the thing that the
way it has to work okay what is this for
this is for so you understood this use
case right and this also comes up in the
quantum circuits case that essentially
we're dealing with two to two functions
here all right that's not what we're
normally dealing with something like you
know applying a function f it can be
applied to many arguments but it's
always going to return one thing this is
dealing with at least a simple case of a
of knitting in a function that has
multiple outputs multiple return values
that makes sense
and I don't know whether there are other
cases I mean what would be other things
that we can imagine doing with functions
with multiple return values I mean this
one is basically you've got an existing
thing a list and certain positions in
that list you are pulling out you're
doing something to them and you're
sticking stuff back in now now I mean in
a sense things like I mean I don't know
that I don't ever use this but I mean we
have this very neat to capability that
you can say you know XY equals YX to
swap the values of x and y right
essentially doing a parallel assignment
and what this is doing is it's kind of a
parallel you know it's a it's some kind
of parallel apply I think a good example
here is a function accumulate it takes a
list and returns a different list and
therefore we could say if I have a range
of 10 how do I accumulate the first
three elements and put them back so with
your function
ARF accumulate one two three of range
thing yeah exactly right but is actually
no it's not what it would do it won't
work because notice that accumulate of
one two three oh yeah exactly yeah yeah
so I think it's clear if you evaluate
your definition of ARF and apply it on
some longer actually sander on our live
stream is asking why is this function
not the equivalent of this
and the answer is it is basically it's a
functional equivalent of that yes this
would be for one-dimensional cases yes
it would be right I mean that is
certainly a clear way to say that it is
the functional equivalent of that so the
question now is what would you call I
mean what we're trying to do is have
something which does not require you to
name exper right right so we're trying
to back out yeah that's a really good
observation thank you um okay so now the
question would be and and so Jose is
pointed out correctly that pause should
be able to be something which isn't just
a one-dimensional sequence of things
like this but couldn't be for example
well some kind of 2d specification I'm
not quite sure I think there are
examples if you go if you see this
examples at the end I think it will be
clear this so we started with this array
this matrix of ones and now we won't
accumulate data Evernote for example one
column yes right and so what you're
doing there is you're giving a list of
the positions except has for example
right yeah okay fine that's a consistent
thing to do
yeah you look great to hafnium and
missing sunette yes okay so the question
before us is what should we call this
function
so what we've got you know it's some
sort of position map no because we don't
really have it's not like map because it
isn't per element right it's not per
element it takes a whole gulp yes but
yes I was trying to obstruct outdated
position list okay so what this thing
looks like makes it look like is it's
more like a root it's not really a
replace it's an apply apply position
apply but it's look like apply
accelerator not an apply exactly it's
not to replace in any head rewrite
sander
livestreams making a comment that i
don't fully understand the ant at equals
operator would make this easy well he's
still thinking about the L value version
of the function area right yes
no actually okay the yes I mean we're
trying to avoid an L value right because
in order to have the whole point is to
have a functional version of this where
you don't have to name the construct
that you're dealing with yes we had been
dis thinking about that research reset
part which would do what he wants yeah
yes I understand I mean right this is
yes right this is some kind of optimized
yeah okay let's let's go back to this
what we what we're really trying to do
is okay so let's understand what are
some other assignment II things so for
example replace part is a famous example
is is the simpler version of this right
replace part says take part number 2 and
replace it with X okay and this is doing
something a little bit like replaced
part yeah it's a pity that replaced part
if we we can say 2 comma 3 goes to X but
actually list of lists to list 3
yeah
exactly and if this was able to accept a
list X Y on the Left we will be almost
there you mean on the right hcx actor on
the right these are the facts we need to
be able to replace it with a list
exactly yes that's what I mean that if
we put a list here X Y it will put two
lists instead of today this BC the
doesn't read exactly um so again I don't
think it's a replace because it's a
function application right I wonder
whether this is a sequence belongs to a
second the sequence family sequence
something why because it's extracting a
sequence of elements doing something
with them to put out a sequence actually
world for list we were kind of alighting
that is here yes but in the in the
sequence family we are also working with
lists yeah no no I agree okay so I had a
univariate function function of some
list yes okay so let's look at these
names that were here so okay I think we
all agree what the function is supposed
to do now we just need a name that isn't
completely obscure okay so how would you
explain to somebody what this function
does extracts elements transforms them
and puts them back that description
makes no sense to me because what have
you know if I extract you know the top
left corner you know the bottom right
corner or something that's three rows
down and two over I don't understand
what it means to extract them and put
them back at least not if you're
applying to them you know you're putting
the back in the same positions that's
the whole point
yeah so you're only two so you're only
what does it mean to put them in the
same position so you're saying see this
is this is where I get confused because
you have a I thought you you're taking
sort of multiple things and trying to do
something yes we're taking multiple
things
like position seven eight and nine okay
seven nine and fourteen okay okay and I
think Stephen if you copy the definition
that that there is at the end the the
one I gave is a bit simplified with
respect to yours no a bit up there this
AR f pause I think that explains what we
are done which is exactly what the three
steps of of Brett yes Sandra is
suggesting apply part it's also pointing
out that it's yeah related to my back
it's on the entire thing
I'm just looking at examples of this and
other other libraries and what they're
called but I can I mean as I pointed out
in the email this isn't this isn't
exactly new that there's other there are
libraries that do things like this in
other programming languages that's never
nothing new Under the Sun yeah kind of
and I mean we could try to look for
unfortunately when I look at like those
libraries they tend to have really short
terse or just symbolic looking names for
this irrelevant I mean if somebody come
up with a brilliant name it would be
good but if they haven't I wouldn't
count on update part no it's too generic
sounding I mean I modify that isn't
right either because it's not also just
for transmute again so so what would be
slightly longer version of what that
said that'd be in extract certain parts
eats them in a list and then puts them
back into corresponding
yeah that's correct that's what it's
doing we just don't have anything which
with names like modify because modifies
suggests in place modification which
this is not right
I mean rearranged it's not it's no
guarantee that the things stay anything
like the same so okay so that one
question is is that the curried form
that we primarily emphasize or do we
give in your version here right we could
also give your ARF pause F pause exper
possibly or even FX / pause I think that
we can have both like Muppet so map at
so this will be the on curried form
right FX / pause yep so let's see if we
can name that this is so similar to
Muppet
what does B compose at interesting what
does that mean
alright so composed of FX gives you f of
X so we construct at I mean isn't that
construct what is the difference between
solely univariate I thought composer
been deprecated yes that's why we
introduced construct so compose did two
things one is composition the other is
construct right if you did FG compose F
G X you would seeing the second yeah
so that was the confusion with composed
that it was doing two very different
things at the same time right but now in
this case I mean the reason why compose
is better than construct is that it's
right it's not it's not it's not
Ferrari right it takes one less than
specific yeah right I know but but but I
still think composed suggest something
look what what this is I mean the terms
that would come to mind are in place
modification perhaps that sounds like an
elbow you think I know it's that's way
wrong and that those are the those are
the terms if you start trying to explain
it to somebody
let me see okay I had some crazy ideas
over here like multi-part Curry so what
would be the version of these that
doesn't use positions in the same way
that we have map and map but he would
try to remove the positions what would
it be well we can't do that because we
couldn't have a curried form land you
know I'm trying to find the name a
simpler name so is this like construct
but why is it constructed or because
it's really running the function in a
sense and then putting the results back
reconstruct I mean a very ridiculous
name will be something like replaced
thread extractors absolutely
incomprehensible absolutely
incomprehensible um the problem is it's
really not a map because it's only doing
it once you're right that makes it more
like a construct so if instead of posts
we have all what's that action it means
F is acting on the whole expression yes
it is exactly what constructors it is F
on that expression it's just that this
expression happens to you so do you
climb in here so you're saying that I
don't think that's correct
imagine that post is all okay let's
still do a specific case okay so let's
do this and you say
ARF paws unfortunately have to have it
actually returned let's use accumulate
as the function here yeah it's got to
return some of the same like yep so
accumulate of all and then
and why is it full or struct all doesn't
work did you need a list list of lists
mapped yeah exactly so that's equivalent
to accumulate of range too
so construct of accumulated common range
to reading too much binary okay so in
essence we are adding they add to this
operation you're right wow that's pretty
[ __ ] weird okay so let's imagine what
is constructive and saying it's
documentation that's very precise some
version where it you know where it's
what does the Varig thing mean because
the virág thing the point is it is
picking up I'm still confused about why
this even works okay so you're saying
here if I say ARF pause here and this
thing here is the list just four five
six additional lists it has to be a
position expect not about the spec okay
but I don't agree with that design I
mean I think that it should be what the
point is that then we cannot use it in
matrices first yes we can we just have
to do the
case we look the matrix case look we can
perfectly well have lists I 1 I 2 I 3
okay and if you want to use it I think
we should make the matrix case require I
1 J 1 I 2 J 2 etc see what I'm saying we
really have to have this case work this
this case is going to be the very basic
case and the you know realistically you
never want just to single one of these
right you're always wanting multiple
things so you're always gonna want the
outer list otherwise why would you do
this you would just use map hat if you
just want well not even map at you would
just use if you just want one element
yes you're effectively doing that bad we
we can do that it is that it's not
exactly what extract - because extracts
whistle list I know it's okay fine I'm
not better I'm not arguing for it to be
exactly extract I think it needs to be
this okay but the question is then what
does this do what is the way to think
about this so this is taking those
arguments somebody hands me curl
Michelle on the live stream suggest
partial the arrangement yeah yep that's
a I mean that's way off in the math
transform at yeah unfortunate transform
at it's just too general sounding I mean
it's a very specific thing it's it's you
know applies the function gets back a
result of the same shape sticks the
things back so in that thing that's
violated then we're going to sequence
eyes those inner lists what do you mean
that's a position spec it's like a list
of positions in a matrix yeah the list
of 2d positions
yeah so that if the this thing here is
yes sir so someone's asking why don't
have the option to return the results
somewhere else on the list no I don't
think so because I think as soon as you
do that well I did think about that
actually I did think about that I think
it becomes too incredibly weird in that
case I mean you could imagine something
where you say you know pick the thing up
so let's say I mean that would in
principle be possible well you can do
that with a rule syntax yeah well they
like a green certain reinsert you said
yeah
okay does this work with insert is there
a way to do this with insert by doing is
can you say we would have to delete
first we will have to I know it was too
horrible right but that's why I replaced
part is the right thing right when this
is brought up in tutorials at least in
the tutorials that I read in functional
programming in the libraries it's almost
always brought up as a way to like mock
state right which is which is why I
think my original suggestion was not map
I'm sorry what was a modified modified
say that because because it's it's not
actually modifying anything right I I
get it but shouldn't call it modify if
it isn't modifying anything but I take
your point I mean it's it's the basic
use that this function has in these
libraries as its introduced is to just
emulate a function that goes of course
of course of course right the point I
was making earlier about the nested list
right now you have something that's
neither apart spec nor positions they're
not neither apart spec nor and extract
spec right I know I know
well I mean I think we have enough
confusion between those two that we
shouldn't introduce yeah but I think
there's no choice because these are the
two use cases that we care about are you
know this function is a little bit
different in the way that it works
let's not address that for a second okay
I think that one is a is you know I
think there really isn't a hell of a lot
of choice there but but I think the the
real question is what how to think about
this thing and I agree actually okay so
let's let's consider the more extreme
case okay here's a more extreme case oh
boy let's imagine this case here let's
imagine that that function f is actually
a two to one function why not allow that
we're good yeah I I still think this is
a construct add with every reconstruct
an interesting reconstruct that is very
interesting that's interesting but
that's the first one of these that
actually it doesn't seem totally crazy
to me because I still see it very
related to my path to construct and it
has their retool to reiterate the fact
that you are coming back to the same
expression yeah my live stream someone
with handle john malkovich suggests
rewrite list rewrite is just not a word
we've used rewrite see the problem is
either reconstruct nori right I like the
REE but neither reconstruct nor rewrite
I understand that construct reminds one
of the constructor op you know function
that we have all right let's just
summarize what we look reconstruct at is
the least crazy one that I think so far
it's a very weird though if you saw them
in a piece of code go ahead they're the
two arguments are the same so it's a
scum expression and the ad at the end
represents the third argument which is a
position spec like my bad and replace
part yeah I understand the concerns the
reconstruct right I wonder about rewrite
at reconstruct almost sounds makes it
sound like it's broken you're getting
torn apart state somebody's just joining
the discussion is asking us what we're
talking about well summarize just for a
second this is a function that is well
let's see if we can describe what it
does function that collects silence from
all s transforms them and then puts them
back where they were for example in a
sorting Network it can take this list of
this it could it could take elements for
nine and apply the sort function to
elements for nine putting those back in
the list
honestly rewrite at is not totally
stupid
I think you know the sound are
suggesting change at that the problem
with rewrite at the difficulty that I
have with it is it doesn't quite suggest
that you are that's kind of interesting
I mean it's it's some it doesn't quite
give primacy to the F function which is
doing the rewriting yeah in other words
if you see that it's saying rewrite by
the way do I have a file where I'm
storing stuff about this this function
or not not in so you only sent email
about it but last week or something you
know I think I sent it mice I don't
think that was the kid from a meeting so
of course I don't have a name for it so
we're nothing it's gonna be another 10
minutes figuring out what the names of
we have a generic place for ILD
functions we usually put things and
miscellaneous if you want to use
language functions let's put it under
off because we kind of know what that is
yeah I was looking at all the write
functions we have they're all quite
different
yes we're getting close to a name we've
got some some I like the idea of
Riesling or other because I think that
that's good
Rican buying that no apply at as being
suggested here but I don't think
I thought about apply at the problem
with apply at is it's not doing an apply
because apply does this and this is just
doing this yes and I like three because
it's taking the output and and that
thing that you wrote in 169 is wouldn't
go constructor combined positions
somebody it's just in reapply at no what
what are you suggesting I don't know why
you like combine because it's not really
combining well you're taking multiple
elements you're applying a function to
them and then you're you know sticking
them where they were and where those
things so you're taking some combination
of these elements and using it to fill
in those slots remix no this
you guys are getting I mean so on the
live stream Netra is suggesting replant
because like you know we've had some of
our sow and reap some of our that one
was that was a was a nod to to the
cornfields of Illinois I think and
actually there's a good name so I like
so but we certainly considered that a
moment of of agricultural ISM I think
okay but let's summarize what the
function is supposed to do okay so this
function we'll call it off for the time
being of f comma x per comma pause well
it's a list of positions P 1 P 2 P 3
what does that do
I mean we would normally say applies F
even though it's not in the formal sense
applies F to the list of elements p1 p2
over that's I would say of the list of
elements at positions okay well let's
say to the elements at positions p1 p2
p3 of list taking the result well I mean
I think it's important to say the list
of elements because it's not going to so
what did I say before that this is
basically reinserting the results back
it to the same positions it's a little
bit con kelly said okay so let's just
let's just look at the other forms here
so the other form is that's the curried
form and then another form is F and then
we could allow P 1 2 P P 1 P 1 P P 2 2 P
2 P or we could allow the same thing
where we could allow 1 P 2 arrow P 1 P
etcetera I think I think we can allow
both of those and those that could be a
different length list if we wanted to
these ones
reinsert
back at positions P 1 P P 2 P etc right
okay so and then the other cases are F
of F comma I 1 J 1 I 2 J 2 thought that
one operates on elements I 1 J 1 etc of
list okay so what is this function okay
so we have functions like map filter it
I don't know why it's filtering we tried
to have a bunch of functions with the
word filter in them in connection where
we have lots of filters but they don't
mean anything like this um we also have
block map which does something yet
different in block map is mapping on
non-overlapping sub lists
[Music]
so I mean yes I agree that the most
obvious version would be something like
apply at I mean the question is okay you
know apply at it's just completely
unobvious that apply at you know what
does it do with the results basically
the affirming with apply art is that one
expects that is going to be related to
apply in the same way that moppet is
related to map so you will just apply
the head F at those positions okay so
yeah that's not good okay so we've got
things like rewrite at I wished that
this had that rewrite had a better sense
of applying a function what are our
various other things that apply function
I mean there's things like fold
obviously that apply functions
let's come back to the modify suggestion
for a second even though I don't like it
we have very little um I just don't see
how modify it can help us at all because
not really doing that it's it's taking
this function see it would be very good
to be able to get the idea that the
thing what does it do let's look back at
the names that I'd come up with wherever
they were okay so this was an idea that
that was a way of naming the curried
form as a function of some kind what
about if we see these as rejoining lists
but it's not really joined because the
list can be don't have to be you know
sequential elements yes yes I was
thinking that we had a list we split it
and don't return it but yeah what about
a mutate type thing it's that too
general I mean I like mutate I mean
there are aspects of it at least that I
like the fact that you know in terms of
like genes it tends not to be the entire
no DNA sequence that's changed at once
no it's you know there you're right but
that's an interesting thing to meet
sounds too close to L values and
mutability
well the act certainly it doesn't you
know suggests that it's happening to the
thing itself I so to speak rather than
but it is mutating something I have to
say that's the one that least upsets me
so far
mutate so crazy I mean I don't know the
if we see something in code that says
mutate at so what we would see is mutate
at that's pretty weird
yes Ana is suggesting function at which
was a little bit similar to my okay
let's just look at function act for a
second
I think Turing is the crazy because I
think you would expect things like you
know formal variables and things inside
it and so on yeah look I think mutate
ass is the least crazy of these things
so far you know we've had modifier at
the live stream the problem and modify
it is really suggests that it is doing
an in-place modification mutate might
suggest that too but the word mutate is
you have to be a bit more technical to
think that's what it might be doing well
in the same time
out there and change I don't think those
are good I think those are think we're
better off with something that sounds a
bit more technical or at least a bit
more abstract this will be a useful
function that there'll be a bunch of
code that can be written quite nicely
with this function and I like I mean and
you know you'll be able to do things
like this which basically means take
those two elements I don't even know how
you do that right now other than by I
mean yeah you can do that by doing an
insert a replace part yeah that is a
replace part that would be done that
would the obvious way to do that would
be a replacement part in exper of one
arrow f of X / five six what I keep
thinking of as a relationship with Matt
but so if if the notation of map had had
in the second argument there rule
notation this could be map itself it's
it's something like it's taking these
objects and putting them back in these
observers very interesting idea okay so
let's look at map that as map address
today okay so map at range of 10 and
then we I mean there's a little bit of
screeners here right because that
doesn't that has the horrible thing of
having to do this and so what you're
saying is if map out or there's an
interesting idea
if map at no it's not right it's not
right it's not right it's not right
because map at doesn't take them in a
full gulp it takes them one at a time
it's just not the same thing yes we
would have
interpret things when we have their
orientation or perhaps we can try to
solve this two problems at the same time
we invent something that we can put as
what could be some wrapper around their
list that would interpret already what
you want without the additional list
I mean map is not a multi gulp I mean
it's not a multi fish gulp thing I mean
it's just map just goes and looks at sub
parts the other it's not a sequence I
mean not that it is necessarily a
sequence but this is a multi-part well
I've seen you serves introducing
annotation of extended position which
precisely does that it's specifying and
for sequence of objects a collection of
objects which we already have several
list based things mm-hmm yeah what do we
do with the sequence for meaning right
but the sequence family is all adjacent
you know yes I understand
I guess I'm trying to put the function
matter as please pointing out if we have
a level speck on the applying part of
the of the map that wouldn't do it
because this is going to take disjoint
elements look I like very much the the
notation here I'm liking a lot I just we
just need a name for this thing so I'm
going through dictionary lookup of
things that start with a re and I'm up
to reforge oh boy now we've got a
blacksmith analogy
so the arity of f will match the
cardinality at each position given by
the position spec the arity of f so f is
being given what's going to happen is
you're given the the things at positions
you know 2 6 and 18 or something and now
that's got to return a result r1 r2 r3
which will be reinserted back into
positions 2 6 and 18 except that we're
also potentially allowing putting them
back in different positions with a
different arity I mean in principle we
could allow yeah so these would be
actually we should call them r 2 r 6 r
18 I mean one problem by the way the @
thing is that that suggests a particular
you know resolution of the of the
extract part dichotomy of part numbers
and it will be sort of nice to to
somehow they lied that in this case AG
we are way over time and we have not
solved this problem maybe we could try
to implement this function under the
name mutate at which I don't think can
be its final name I think that's
something in the Lee family and if Brett
has finished his I bet if we omit
rejigger now the it's okay we can let's
let's just select let's see how we do
this string take hash
, 2 equals equals equals re am i right
I'm getting only verbs here so it's a
lot shorter
um ya recollect will be lovely except
that it has a rather different meaning
um reinstate boy there's things which
are very close they're just not right
replicate retread you can end up with
rethread next um boy this is some
retrofit interesting that's an
interesting word yeah it's not right
it's just interesting in somehow alright
what are the other I mean the other
concept that we have here what are the
other things for I mean it's almost like
shuffle except it's not shuffle it's a
you know where words like it's not
vacation that the things are left the
same
common for the I mean and it's not
shuffled by you know but shuffle by I
see I salute your saying so you're
suggesting I mean even though the
argument order is weird for a by
function noting that the F is some but
the presence of the F is like a by all
right with right because it's not a
buyer to buy unfortunately unless we
extend what buy means no no it's not
yeah it's full of smart powers actually
kind of like shuffle with why is it
shuffling anything I mean in the case of
the sorting Network it might be
shuffling something but why is it if you
have to generalize case where you're
allowing to say where the results go
yeah that's something else is pointing
out on the live stream that shuffle
sounds non-deterministic which is true
that horrendously wrong yeah so I must
say that these discussion sounds very
similar to discussing we had months ago
on the names of construct how to what
separation of applying given that we
cannot do supply I think which is why I
said constructors on reconstruct is
almost right except that not barred but
it the fact that this veronika was an
extension just to make it a bit more
useful but the main use of construct is
the two argument case okay so what would
you suggest with construct you suggest
and construct that reconstruct that
that's pretty weird
I mean we
Strutt like it was broken well I'm just
trying to follow the analogy with
construct you know if we chose construct
well construct is fine because it's it's
not right I mean the problem with
construction right is that it then goes
back in right yes construct that you
would expect to just extract and apply
but not then throw away the rest yes
that's why it's for constructing an
expression after constructing the de
some expression we reom construct a
place with that construct in place
reconstruct using I don't think using is
up I mean construct I hate to construct
in place because it's it's really not
our typical naming convention but let's
see if does the construct in place
actually mean the right thing or maybe
construct part like replace parts that
it's construct part that's interesting
that's interesting
except it doesn't get back
I mean construct in place remove there's
a more elegant way to say that but in
place is an important idea except that
in place might suggest mutable data
structures which it says normal oh boy
these things always so difficult so
Sandra is asking what is the distinction
function that ends with hat and a
function that ends with part as a map at
replace part well yes that sort of
replace part is not really replacing
it's not like it is replacing a part
that's that's what it does yeah I think
I think the difference is that the
replaced part has on the left-hand side
the position spec or the part of the
spec well at least part the place that
they would expect expression to be
replaced
right replace at would be the thing
which allows me to apply you know do
replace of a particular pattern at
positions 2 5 & 7 right which is a
function we don't have there's replacing
the particular part with a new value
it's not will replace its right
no replace at would be the equivalent of
replace but with particular so that
would be that would be something like
with a pattern you know X blank goes to
x squared or something at positions one
and three exactly yeah we don't have
that I mean that's another thing we
might one day consider but we don't have
that
let me just after the
but that has a that would be a clear
thing we know what that's gonna be oh
gosh this is crazy
well this is I feel a little bit better
because I did think about this for a bit
when I was trying to invent this
function um okay
Steve and I would just like to say that
I have another meeting I know I've gone
over a meeting I was supposed to have
here so I really should go even though
we were just warming up here on the
livestream
let's see we should suggest what people
if somebody comes up with a brilliant
idea here much they send it mmm
I'll tell you what somebody is going to
put an email address in the live stream
of where they should send their
brilliant suggestion because we'd really
like it um and um I bet you could send
it to suggestions of warm calm and I
hope our beautifully tuned bureaucracy
after all these three decades is such
that that would actually get to the
right place I think it's good chance it
would um well though nobody on this call
has anything to do with what happens to
them to that particular stream um
alright let's try to implement this
thing will implement it under the name
mutate at which we don't expect to
survive um and have a play with it I
think we can implement at a top level so
let's see we have one um yes we need a
we need a website that somebody's
pointing out on a live stream that we
need am voting in submission I'm not
sure voting is the best idea but but um
at least a a website to send stuff Oh a
synchronously from these actual um
actually you know what you can add
comments to the to the live stream
archives right although I don't know
when the weather the archives show up
immediately
anyway so somebody other than me is
gonna solve that problem I hope all
right sort of twitchy mailing list or
email address I don't know but we should
have something maybe we should have a
live stream at Wolfram calm that simply
is for people to make suggestions based
on things they see on the live stream